how's the Gomer as man is pure welcome
back to second send the second son of
the safe Sega Sonic Sonic the Hedgehog's
and run fast I just wanted to talk to
her okay
to see if maybe she could help us out oh
you are not doing the pouting Reggie
thing are you
you know I hate that you know someone
like that should be free to roam the
streets are you forgetting who else is
someone like that oh yes
no I know I'm your brother and your
brother is asking for your help and
trying to stay alive if you won't do it
for me then do it for the tribe fine
thank you
I need to see what else this new power
can do and you are my go-to guy when it
comes to finding the quarians there I
sent it for the tribe and you thank you
I'll let you know what I get no I don't
want to know what you get by counting
Reggie in fact you know those glowing
boxes the Dukes put up all over town
well I think I figured out a way to use
them like tap into more powers for me I
was gonna try it out on the new neon
power you gave me and I thought maybe
you'd like a tag along nobody taught me
through the new stuff I already back my
feeling with it today what Elma there's
my sweet girl there's supposed to be one
of those things at a second and named
yeah I seen him before me there
I don't know why but I kind of prefer
the smoke attack because you could go
through Benson [ __ ] now you have to run
up I don't know it was more convenient
whoa he's on the unsign does that mean
I'm eating pizza then if I suck that up
why can't I go on this I want to suck up
the pizza come on there we go
went straight to my junk must be some
magnetism can we go in here nope
hey hutch it's over here hi I'm cool
kinda with trackers of me don't get
along well wait'll you see this
umm what am I gonna show her what seemed
like such a good idea
constipation time
what if again I can turn them I can
mummify them with disco did it hey you
guys seen a girl kind of short purple
hair oh let's say if I shoot their feet
oh good karma winged it you're welcome
give them new shoes
everyone will be fab being mine you
didn't roses town track you know I think
they were just on patrol I found another
one I love you science to find it see it
it's a neon marker uh yeah got it just
follow those fudge King is she talking
about
do you like your new shoes you're
welcome your Wow go oh excuse me I'm a
lady
suck it I follow Gani garbage that was
fun sir hey smokes you want it on it
I'm not smoke I'm smokin ah I don't know
why in this game constipation is good
did we get the bomb down awesome I love
shooting neon balls don't you okay yeah
yeah you still need help trap enemy
don't murder my samosas army gone here
join us
I guess we're called noses now oh I
don't even have to substitute Edom
there you go only one holy one there we
go wonderful okay just [ __ ] nine
please you got
I'll go find another one of those things
don't be racist heavy guy okay I think I
got the next one just keep following the
markers so how do you like killing those
dealers that's a [ __ ] joke
fainted no maybe we should tone it down
with the dealers you going soft on me be
Hey we have powers they don't means we
have to be the better people you know
time a little slack now and then yeah
think about it let's go get yourself the
more power I mean we have the pirate
power of disco there's probably super
jelly feel lost this is really it oh my
god
it is here can we just walk together
please
yeah yeah okay this is the cinder blast
you first
how convenient Oh what oh there we go
why did Ludacris say when he crossed the
street
boom [ __ ] if this was real life which
attacked which would you prefer to have
rose neon our smoke yeah I agree
me too I wish she would just tell me
where the [ __ ] she is going I wouldn't
have to look like an idiot dude bro teen
Meagan I want to go there I want to go
there right now Shark Week is that a Sly
Cooper I just like him for what the [ __ ]
okay was awesome that the same studio
he has a very slight cooperage running
animation actually I never realized
today the hell are we
what
oh this is the right place I'm saying
let's release the crack oh my god this
game is like Pokemon after all a new age
oh my god it's amazing
does he only get murdered my god
that was awesome any time you want to
actually hang around for one of these
things oh yeah so that's come small time
for going up the food chain a little
find a supplier what I lost some I'd be
glad to tag along next trip you make up
the food changes I think I've ever
actually changed anything before sure
I'll be a day with a death ball I'll
give you a call if anything comes up we
did it for us hi Kai I try to invent
something new but I don't work out hi
fine oh so now we can choose if you want
to go on the good mission or the bad
mission but the high five decide nice
hat sir Wow let me get to your paranoid
shoes
there you go new shoes for everyone you
get new shoes you get new shoes
everyone gets new shoes damn it feels
good to be a sanic a real gangsta-ass
sanic places cards right a real gangster
as sanic never runs his [ __ ] mouth
because there are real gangsta-ass sanic
never start one that's couch it's gonna
get wet
ha lazy girl get people to see the
powers to steal ok promise you won't be
mad but the good news is you can start
without me
Oh face the danger alone gee that is
good news listen I found out a major
truck ship came in a couple days ago and
it's stored on some clocks there at the
marina
all right on some boats at a marina
solid details I need it's a big shipment
so it'll probably be the house and this
group uses a dolphin a sort of their
mark so I booked right hang on a boat
better but don't wait you never know
when they'll start off wrote about so
what held you up girl stuff you clinics
girl stuff you girls down come back
until he sold out his friends and told
me all about this goddamn drug shipment
that doesn't sound like girls staff at
ha ha ha ha ha pink pink pink girls are
pink sorry I said it but it's not a
boxing ring what he couldn't wait a few
more minutes let's tell some drugs
people
cuz they only come out at night oh hello
what is he doing that was amazing hahaha
cheapo Fairmount grab all the Pope ball
you get a poke ball you get sliced into
half
actually chief oh yeah Mound doesn't
matter having trouble finding folks at
the marina
yeah drugs betcha I'm gonna tag all the
boats with drugs to make it easier for
you to know which one to take out can't
you ever go like five minutes without
tagging stuff how does she know that we
never talked about this
alright it's time to do use it here we
go ha ha
oh my god it's awesome I took a I'd like
to guys amazing oh I took out everyone
they're all dead ha ha ha they're
literally all dead got them all
just like Pokemon I told you bros no one
ever listens when I say that games
aren't like Pokemon no one you wonder
why let's tag it that batch new color
made it easy for you I didn't get to
spray though but it's cute so it's ok
hashtag skill full side hashtag bullseye
hashtag skill hashtag I'm alone me
hashtag please kill me shoot 4 legs make
everyone a fabulous little princess
brofist no profits man hombre no boss
everyone knows drug dealers keep their
stash out in the ring come on come on
Duke the ebike all right it's marking
hurt something you heard something
there's someone inside what the hell
were you
that's random haha alright now we
destroyed fetch didn't tell me there'd
be guys party no.3 Davis must be using
they're hookers as human shields that's
pretty smart
I mean no that's terrible oh god that's
a lot of them there's gonna be awesome
rows Joe oh my God look at that map
look at that may up Oh
minecraft knotch overlord is gonna come
all over there we go
here we go power of families oh my god
so much bad so much major sex well don't
do that again
so they're destroying the castle wait a
mouse make them come to us
oh good sit and wait my favorite
strategy I wanted to join me on the roof
here and enjoy the fireworks
how about to light up all the truckball
don't you just hate when you have a neon
sign and you come back home from work
and you're like someone stole my neon
ready let's light up the bay oh we still
haven't learned that attack that's like
the ultimate laser awesome attack
well that did that didn't it
high five maybe oh god no maybe not with
her well that's three less evil dolphin
boats in the world three less porpoise
boats don't worry it's a common mistake
yeah high five rise
wake up done diddly did Paul I didn't
even Charlie moving some stuff to their
main location we should follow him let
him lead us to it okay
I'm okay you know that neon light is not
very discreet top so we don't spook up
you just got to be careful my visa all
is safe i drained the smoke I change oh
my god there you go you keep running
darling it's not getting away were you
talking to my they pulled into the alley
this must be the place
all right so what's the plan uh get him
get him isn't a plan that's a genius
plan hi oh it's a show-off
I love show-offs I'll just stay here
um okay maybe not maybe not a great idea
like the music yeah yeah what's going on
lads
schmuck
smell [ __ ] smoke come out
swag really really we don't need it in a
real world and we don't need in a fake
word okay world somebody the truck let's
check it out in the swag shop maybe
first I have to buy myself a new swag no
it must contain myself I suppose all
right ladies come on let's go yes the
bad men are gone
go Live Love just not professionally you
want to get clean now's the time there
won't be any more drugs on the street
don't screw it up and yeah good luck
over they think a couple of lowlife
bioterrorist will ever get bang for
saving people yeah I think you might
have saved me
so what are you gonna give up on your
whole ritualistic murdering of drug
dealers it's like half your charm oh
yeah
what's the other half actually that was
it you just the one
don't worry not given up on my passions
just mine it's a new ones Oh like boxing
is that like your whole attempt at a
tender moment ah you are a sentimental
psychopathology come on let's just get
the rest of these drugs in the harbor
maybe we can get a few fish strung out
man hook a dolphin hey you like me
I just noticed that that is adorable by
the way I just noticed that his shirt
the back of his shirt changes depending
on if we're infamous or hero or whatever
I don't know that's pretty cool
cool detail there you go that one
changes hey hey I gotta go hook up with
the other woman in my life why does she
have concrete power you guys can you
hook up by the way I think your brother
would have been real proud of what you
did I mean killing the dealers
destroying the drugs and freeing the sex
slaves right of course
well I'm sure he would have loved me
whew whoops we done good I'd like to see
the Lyoness TV Dockers make this look
bad I mean what's the mad about us I
don't understand such great people
never heard a salamander skull never
would we hurt anyone Moses join us
we got the sender blasting my Jigar nuke
alright let's use it it song
it's gonna be awesome
spaceship oh-ho look a bad guy
oh come on not now Betty I got word of a
ramped up to unity presence over the
lantern on doing hiding there sounds
like the place we'd be later right now
this is a conference call
I fed hey Abigail might be worth
mentioning that that bridge was broken
up like the 520 but powerless they ain't
built erect a bridge yet that we can't
can't cross right hey I'm not the sod
reg Wow sounds like you're in completely
confident and trustworthy and you know
why don't you call me if you get there
he pays the bills remember the bridge
gave me to me I tried oh we're going in
here oh my god
I saw son how do we do that
how in the hell no I wish I had an
awesome fortress like that Oh awesome
what do they do
Oh bad move man ah I don't know why they
keep thinking that 100 brofist murdering
people like it's nobody's business girl
no cheating goodbye ha ha turns out
they're a kilise heels up their asses up
their asses ha ha ha ha these Auto turds
they get a lot of fire here who is he
talking to I'm trying ok
stop it right up the ass I didn't say it
he's dead don't look at me like that
don't look at me like that
Oh like that huh
okay wasn't it keep looking then keep it
keep looking keep looking okay now you
need to stop this and do too much for me
too much
calm down stop looking I'm cereal stop
I'm not gonna milk your titties okay
that is it yeah I knew finally yeah not
we're finding that uh uh guys don't
snipe me while I drained his smoke for
[ __ ] sake you just hold eggs okay
- ow
[ __ ] Oh nail dead oh my god you know
what you know what [ __ ] you in your
tower [ __ ] and [ __ ] you and your tower
mate oh this guy reminds me a little bit
of Jesse Pinkman action I think inviting
awesome
all right we almost made it to her
little Tower of moves Oh guys stop
hiding behind your toys huh
shouting shot a shot a shot a one down
two to go
girl nice shield you got there sir I bet
it's [ __ ] gone who's shooting me now
they're still alive Rachel joined the
smartest clan or five million
subscribers now let the trail of bodies
and bulls across this bridge
fetch whoa short attention spans this
looks like a good place for a boss man
mister - yeah
lady you are hell on bridges you know
that so you recognize me you betcha
you're the one that had me dead to
rights a couple weeks ago and just let
me walk away you've changed since then
you mean the smoke thing yeah it's new
huh
I hear you've learned a new trick you've
expanded your arsenal I expanded my arse
alright I'm just a lowly smoke guy
we'll see she reminds me of someone that
I know it's really weird
yes that's doing nothing for me what if
she has that smug ass face oh my god -
she had a sad I know she has a private
die no no that's too tiny for a dino and
a big deal it's just a giant oh my god
if we're gonna die ow I'm not water
anything about water sorry oh come on
what did I say one millisecond ago Jesus
and what they haven't learn I'll smoke
up the smoke
all things she said I'm special she's
still talking well the bigger they are
smaller I feel okay what's that a sex
joke
cuz I'm feeling a little uncomfortable
right now okay
welcome to three five videos good damage
there Thank You kids
you're welcome kids stop talking to
yourself cares no one cares come on
video god damn our Ellen's got him
almost got him almost got him what I was
behind cover come on
I don't mean to be that guy but I was
behind cover all right so that's pretty
[ __ ] lame oh but I mean at least now
she knows I wasn't lying when I first
met her
that's my selfie face it's also my
convincing argument face it's the same
face I don't know how that happened
evolution is taught us so much I don't
I've got all right one more yeah Spach
so ugly to like God look here get a
mirror god I don't talk to you so ugly
like I'll talk to Muslim so I think I
can save us both a lot of time here I
just need to leech a little power off
you that's it you want me to just give
you my power I mean not enough to sink
bridges or anything but enough to pull
the concrete daggers out of my friends
yeah and then after that you will never
see me again I've got a better idea
so to be useless to me back in your
little Hubbell how about you stay here
with me kind of like my idea better
uh-oh
Dawson you disappoint me
bet know what just happened
what just happen am i transformer please
amortize warmer I think I'm a Mecca yep
I'm a Japanese robot right now or
Godzilla either way I am a happy man
it's got dama we're gonna goods out
Katella what we're in your district
awesome chinatown yeah yeah that's why
it's Godzilla
well I the lantern district where I was
headed all along
all right well that's great thank you
for watching this episode bros go ahead
and like if you enjoy watching it helps
me out a lot and make spells I'll feel
better English [ __ ] sorry thanks
for watching the episode as always stay
awesome brown bro for years